(lively music)
- Probably gonna embarrass
the (bleep) out of myself.
- I used to be a white guy
in a band full of white guys.
So this is my jam.
(lively music)
- These guys don't look like they'd be
One Republic based on their music.
- I'm gonna say that this is They Frey.
- Oh this is One Direc- One Republic.
- Yes (laughing). I know that one dude in
One Republic wears a hat all the time.
- I thought there were like three people
in One Republic or one.
(lively music)
- It could be alt-J, but look okay,
so it looks like these people are around
their shortest friend and he's pregnant
and he's pregnant and this
is their announcement.
- Oh man, this is hard. They're all white,
they all look the same (laughing).
- It's either Foster The
People or Imagine Dragons
and I think it's Imagine Dragons.
- This one is Imagine Dragons.
Well imagine that I was wrong.
- I'm telling you that one performance
I saw with them and Kendrick Lamar,
this is what those guys looked like.
(lively music)
- Very acoustic looking.
- I don't think this is The Frey
but I know that there might
be a bald guy in The Frey.
- I'm gonna give a really stupid reason
and it's that there's one guy, two others;
one of them is Mumford
and they're the Sons.
- This is The Frey because that's
the lead singer and he's bald and has
a fresh faced look.
Make this hard. Where's the challenge?
(lively music)
- It's either alt-J or Bastille.
I think I might get this
wrong. I feel terrible.
- Final answer for this
one is Arctic Monkeys.
- I'm gonna guess that this is alt-J.
- I don't know, they look really like
grown and sexy and I feel like
Bastille is a grown
and sexy kind of group.
- Ah man, it's Bastille? Man they're too,
I don't want them to be this clean cut.
(lively music)
- Okay, these people
look just like Bastille.
I'm pretty sure you're
playing a trick on me.
- I can see that they won
two Grammy's apparently.
- I feel like Vampire Weekend is maybe
the biggest name so
I'm gonna go with them.
- I went to a Christian College
where everybody's Indie.
It has to be Mumford & Sons.
- I kept getting it
confused with Sanford & Son
so that's why I didn't go for that.
- What's interesting is that the
front man is very recognizable
in some of them to me but if you
took him out I wouldn't know.
- If I went back through all of these
I would still give you wrong answers.
I'm sure I wouldn't remember who
any of these people are.
- Maybe I should broaden my horizons
a little bit, listen to
a few more genre's I'm
not as familiar with.
- Actually the walkaway is
dude, get some diverse
people in these bands man.
There's lots of different cultures
and ethnicities that play music.